it's not going to be long before unlv
will be kicking off its football season
at allegiant stadium sports director
chris matthews joining us now in the
studio with more on spring football as
unlv
looks to win in the fall chris that's
what they're hoping of course it's never
too early to talk football that's the
hope it's been too long for unlv now
football exactly one week into it spring
practice and quarterback competition
already starting to heat up here last
season four quarterbacks fielded snaps
for unlv
primary starter max gillum is no longer
on the roster so the focus is now on
junior and tcu transfer justin rogers
and sophomore
doug brumfield true freshman cameron
freel is also on campus and could be a
factor in that competition
whoever emerges in the spring will have
the difficult task
of improving an offense that was ranked
second to last in the mountain west
last season in scoring those guys have
done a good job coming out
working their tail off in the film room
and pre-practice and post practice and
getting things done
doing it the right way competing
together they know that the expectations
and standards are really high at that
position
cam as a young guy is a true freshman
coming in early who still should be in
high school is doing a really good job
of just
trying to drink through a fire hose and
so
i think so far so good executing the
offense
you know we have our rules and goals and
things that we look for
and i think whoever accomplished those
goals through our camp
throughout the summer and fall camping
so i think will win the job
i feel a lot more confident this year
especially since i got more time with my
team
and just to get like a mesh and a bond
together just more time to just gel and
perfect our crop all right now the
rebels will hold their spring
showcase inside of legion stadium on may
first their first home game
coming up on september 2nd against
eastern
washington